welcome back that world's two biggest
economies are locked in a trade war the
pound is slumping the economy is
contracting recession may be just one
quarter away or is it let's discuss with
two guests Ruth Lee is an economist and
Charles Wells was until a few weeks ago
a special adviser to the Prime Minister
on business and industrial strategy well
we had those pretty grim numbers didn't
we on Friday not point 2 percent
contraction worse than expected total UK
economy shrinking Ruth this does this
feel like the start of a recession not
to me no I mean the point was the second
quarter figure is basically a correction
to the first quarter figure which of
course have been boosted by the pre
Briggs day the original Bridget Day
activity and if you actually look at the
breakdown of the expenditure figures
with GDP you'll see any huge swing from
major stock stock building in the first
quarter to major stop doing it that's
kind of a bumpy road there was a major
stock building and then destocking it
was about a turnaround of about 10
billion pounds which is actually huge so
no recession
I say well then the thing is the
household consumption was at 0.5 percent
which was very similar to the first
quarter and unemployment is very low
it's at record levels since 1974 real
earnings are now rising quite quickly so
with combined with a high honor high
employment and high real earnings growth
that should sustain household
consumption growth going forward but of
course there will be a rocky right I
think there will be bumps in the road
but when you have unemployment rate of
three point seven percent it ain't no
recession okay and jobs I mean do you
know is there something to be worried
about with those nuts in terms of what
people feel people will not be feeling a
recession right now as Ruth says there's
not very much unemployment employment is
actually at an all-time high inflation
'slow all the things that people
associate with economic distress are not
happening right now
wages are rising quite well but the
government won't be wanting to see is
the story of a recession getting out
there and that's all going to be about
the next quarter the next quarter that's
going to be more affected by these
concerns around brexit right now that -
naught point - it might even be revised
away so probably will they want to make
sure that people aren't discussing a
Boris bust in the press rather than the
actual reality of it but you mentioned
breakfast I mean in Ruth you said you
know there is clearly a brexit effect
here
people are preparing for a possible
deadline and not so Breck brexit is
responsible for the for this contraction
is responsible for the boost in the
first quarter and of course then you
just have the destocking of the second
quarter that was the major movement it
was actually a movement on the trade
figures as well but it would be
interesting that as we route to 31st of
October will businesses actually starts
stop building again as they didn't in
the first quarter if that is the case
you actually might find that the third
although what will happen in the third
quarter we don't know but four nice
National Institute of Economic and
Social Research for what it's worth are
suggesting perhaps GDP will grow by 0.2%
in the third quarter but we've got high
employment so it's relaxed are you about
unloading I'm relatively relaxed because
I don't think it was so relaxed before
notice I'm relatively relaxed because
the truth is you wanted a deal though
didn't you well the truth is the deal is
off the table because the withdrawal
agreement it's quite obvious the
Commission is not going to RIT seriously
reopen the negotiations and it's quite
obvious with the withdrawal agreement
can't go through the comments so where
is it it's a it's a No Deal but we're
making preparations and so are the EU
they've made like contingency plans
trade will continue perhaps a few bumps
in the road I think there might be a lot
more than a few bumps in the road and
that one thing that has been weak in the
economy there's been very little
investment despite the fact that firms
have a lot of cash they've all been
saying until I know what I'm investing
in I'm not gonna do it if there's no
deal despite it being it sounds like the
end of a story but it's the beginning of
a whole load of more uncertainty as we
try to work out what is our relationship
going to be with Europe lots of other
deals that need to be struck afterwards
so I'm expecting if there is a No Deal
brexit on the 31st of October that
investment figure might plummet even
further might well get a rating it's
pretty sad yet I mean the point was a
pretty weak though we couldn't even
expect it to be even that got a lot of
cash actually it's not been plummeting
either you got a key in perspective
business investments about 10% of GDP
and it's sort of slightly it came off
last year then it picked up in the first
quarter ironically and then it fell back
a bit in the second quarter it has we
and at this stage of an economic cycle
you would expect business investment to
grow much quicker than it missing out on
a good I agree
and one thing one thing that certainly
has been affected is the pound let's
have a look actually I've got a chart
which we can have a look at showing you
just what's happened to the pound versus
the dollar over the course of the last
few months and this just since the start
of the year down to kind of getting on
for 120 against the dollar now that is
actually the lowest it's been since 1985
kind of Live Aid yeah there was a little
bump in 2016 well you know this this is
a big fall from Sterling
it is and I would contrast that weakness
back then in the 80s the economy was
booming I mean you were still at the
civil service around then it must be a
great times because the economy was
finally growing really really fast
sometimes the pound Falls because of
monetary ease and that's a good news
story this is not a good news story this
is the market saying whatever Britain is
producing you need to charge less for it
because it's it's not as good an economy
as before that's my view on those
dreadful recession but yeah and of
course the dollar was exceptionally
strong but I think more to the point I
think we're down to the levels now of a
sort of early 2017 when there is
undoubtedly a lot of uncertainty
political uncertainty in the markets the
markets don't like uncertainty and it's
not just British it's the prospect of a
Corbin government you've got there are
all sorts of political concerns that are
hanging over the markets about Britain
understandably
that's less let's talk as well jazz you
mentioned and governments and all these
basically own government over the years
and Charles just recently I think you
know your Twitter your Twitter bio says
you're recovering from 30 months in
Downing Street advising on economic
policy so yeah you're in recovery at the
moment but that was that did that feel
like a kind of functional place to be
working it was although I mean this
little seems bizarre all mr. fills
paradise we spent most of our time
trying to think about longer-term policy
most policymaking is about what's gonna
happen next three to five years I mean
transport ministers plan roads that will
be built in five to 10 years that's
where you spend most of your time the
new team are very much focused in like
three to five months and so it felt
functional but it's difficult just for
one very quick question
Cummings a lot of focus on him yeah
here's here's a super spiders that were
you know is it kickin ass bad like him a
special advisor really changed the
country there's it seems to be a
recurring pattern a new government comes
in people focus on some guru like
character who's going to be pulling all
the strings behind the curtain I
personally think they're totally total
exaggerations he's only one man amongst
many most of the MPs are away when they
come back they're going to want to
remind the people behind the curtain
that it's Parliament and MPs who are
meant to be in charge so there's a lot
of over-excitement right now but he's
only one person he doesn't have any
unique answer to all of this any more
than anyone else does